the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers
[Music]
from the director whose films make you
say ooh what's happening or what's
happening or just what was the happening
you like hot dogs right comes his new
film that will make you say well that
happened glass in a world where
Hollywood has turned superheroes into a
billion-dollar business and night is
taking comic-book movies back to their
roots a series of static images
at the superhero movie that's so
grounded all of the superheroes just lay
on the ground and die misses his body
slowly succumbs to the inevitable a
sensation of cold water spreads through
his body your favorite break averse
characters are back like Bruce Willis
doing as little as you'd expect Sam
Jackson
not doing much at all for the first half
he'll be getting out of your room alive
John and James McAvoy doing absolutely
everything else but when these three
finally get together they'll go toe to
toe in scene after scene of intense
therapy can you tell me about Kevin's
parents I think you believe water is
your weakness I've come to the
conclusion that we should perform a
procedure on you this is your MRI David
you two people would think that comic
book characters or something I don't
approve of how they've handled you you
can't possibly explain everything away
right was it our fault for expecting
something else from him night at this
point because this is a twist we
probably should have seen coming he will
keep bringing me back I don't want to be
here together they'll encounter the evil
doctor stable a mysterious ring trying
to Gaslight them into thinking they
don't have powers and she might be right
cuz that's just parkour that's PCB also
PCP PCP that's a lot of PCP and the
super genius plan is to post some
YouTube videos even if they trend
everyone will think it's just a viral
campaign for muscle milk
[Music]
so suit up for the third chapter of a
trilogy that may not have stuck the
landing but at least it's an original
self-financed project from a true auteur
that doesn't feel like anything else in
an oversaturated market but let's be
honest a little bit a whole better with
another Piquet me at the end
story dead in a pool glass half not in
the movie
son of a done Casey ex-girlfriend hi I'm
dr. staple I can't save your baby but I
can do the robot that'll be five
thousand dollars and James McAvoy's SNL
audition prison cell pass salt Bay your
ass what is that anyway it's an internet
guy he's a butcher salt is meat in a lab
right away oh man I didn't realize this
takes place in the same universe of salt
bay a twist to fit even more Game of
Thrones into your eyeballs click the box
to watch our after-show watching Thrones
or if you need to get caught up before
the game concludes check out our Kremen
of the complete series Terry Gilstrap
you are going to be a daddy
you